the u.s has been encouraging allies to
restrict huawei from their
telecommunications networks security
officials say that beijing could force
the chinese company to spy or even
disable countries networks
so far australia and new zealand have
moved to block huawei in their 5g
rollout but some european countries have
hesitated saying that huawei equipment
is much cheaper plus there's no public
evidence that huawei has or could use
its equipment to eavesdrop but even if
allied countries bend to u.s pressure it
may be nearly impossible to extract
huawei from a country's network where
it's already engrained here's why
countries are rushing to test and roll
out 5g networks seeing that the
potential payoffs are immense the first
phase for many carriers will be to
upgrade existing 4g networks that means
attaching 5g components to legacy
infrastructure
and guess where much of that legacy
hardware comes from
huawei
for the first three quarters of 2018 the
chinese company had a 28 share of the
global telecom equipment market nokia
and ericsson are falling behind
take a close look at huawei's presence
in each region
outside of north america the tech
juggernaut outpaces its nordic rivals
so to take huawei out of the network
whether it's 4g or 5g
countries first have to replace existing
infrastructure provided by the company
and that's a big chunk of time and money
carriers have opposed banning huawei
pointing to its superior hardware and
lower prices
take a small u.s rural carrier as an
example
james valley telecommunications says all
of its wireless core network and radios
are from huawei it says it will cost
around five thousand dollars per
subscriber if it has to replace the
entire network given that it's currently
servicing about 10 000 rural customers
the network replacement costs will total
50 million dollars and it goes beyond
just the money tolago research a
wireless technology research firm says a
typical network replacement cycle takes
five to ten years to complete so even if
the us were to ban huawei and 5g
carriers can still expect that huawei
won't be out of the network immediately
[Music]
outside of huawei nokia and ericsson
aren't gaining much favor among european
carriers wireless providers say that
they've been slow to release equipment
as advanced as huawei's
some of huawei's 5g technology can be up
to a year ahead of its western rivals
according to some senior executives
huawei's clout in 5g stems from its
massive research and development budget
in 2017 huawei spent 13 billion dollars
on r d more than its chief rivals
combined the company now owns the most
number of standard essential 5g patents
in the world
some of those are now fundamental
building blocks to 5g
they include one highly prized technique
called polar coding a method for
correcting errors in data transmission
regardless of whether a country chooses
to block huawei there's no way to avoid
paying royalties to license its 5g
technology
with huawei at the center of the 5g race
governments and carriers aren't ready to
abandon it yet
unlike in the u.s officials in germany
and the uk still believe they can allow
some huawei equipment in their countries
if more countries follow the us's advice
knocking out huawei won't be easy
[Music]